do you think you're tough
how tough how much adversity can you
overcome I'm gonna give you a couple of
scenarios and I want you to take a
second
put yourself in each one what would you
do if your boss gave you a negative
review what would you do if you pitched
your startup and the investor passed
what would you do if the company you
spent 20 years building went bankrupt
what would you do if you were diagnosed
with cancer now this guy in front is
thinking whoa whoa that first set of
questions is completely different from
that second set of questions a bad
review is nothing like cancer and I
would say exactly that's the point of my
talk I want to show that not only are
there different kinds of adversity there
are also different kinds of resilience
there are lots of words for this
characteristic resilience emotional
fortitude toughness grit they have
slightly different meanings they overlap
some but by and large they refer to the
ability of individuals to overcome
adversity the problem is that no matter
what words we use we tend to think of it
as a single spectrum really weak people
get overwhelmed by one bad review really
tough people can watch their whole
career go up in smoke and not miss a
step but that doesn't capture all of it
as the guy in front pointed out these
are different kinds of stressors it
would make sense that they would elicit
different reactions and require
different coping mechanisms even from a
tough person this has been bothering me
and I had a sudden burst of clarity when
I realized that these same words that we
use to describe people also have
meanings when they describe the ways
that physical materials deform under
stress in mechanical engineering
deformation and reactive reactions to
stress follows an established pattern
materials first deform elastically which
is to say that they Bend in response to
stress but when the stress is removed
they Bend back this period of elastic
deformation continues to a point called
the yield strength
here's some calculus you ready the area
under the curve between the origin and
yield strength is actually called
toughness toughness is effectively a
measure of how much stress the material
can take and still recover it dovetails
remarkably well with definitions that we
see in psychology in mechanical
engineering there's a little bit more
what happens when stress exceeds yield
strength mechanically it's called
plastic deformation the material bends
permanently or even breaks at what's
known as a fracture point which leads to
what happened to me I fractured my
tibial plateau where the shin bone meets
the knee joint
I was tobogganing and I lost control hit
a pole to mitigate the risks of internal
bleeding I needed surgery that night
surgeons drilled two metal rods into my
tibia two metal rods into my femur
connected all four with an external
fixation device a week later I had
another surgery in which they implanted
a metal rod and a dozen screws all told
the sentence was 16 days in the hospital
12 weeks on crutches a year of physical
therapy and unknown permanent damage
I hit my fracture point literally how
does that happen it's different for
everyone but I'd say we go there when
something really important to us changes
permanently a job a reputation a
relationship or in my case a leg that
idea of permanent damage to the leg that
I had intended to use for marathon
running and mountain climbing the leg
that was maybe a little vainly proud of
hit me hard harder than other challenges
I overcome and somehow I couldn't help
but think what if this weren't my leg
how would I react if this were my
company that was a scary thought I've
long nurtured entrepreneurial
inclinations and the market can dish out
plenty of challenges of its own if I was
flat on my back with a broken leg how
could I reasonably expect to lead in the
face of corporate sized adversity this
is where mechanical engineering of
things made so much sense to me
mechanically there are two types of
deformation reactions in response to
stress inelastic deformation materials
Bend but they end up back where they
were in plastic deformation they bend or
break and need to be rebuilt I think
that people bend to different ways as
well and that means there should be two
different sets of skills for coping with
stress but we mostly talk about one we
call people resilient when they can take
a punch and get right back up being
tough is certainly a good goal it's been
one of mine for a long time but what
about being good at rebuilding what you
do after not just a punch but a knockout
that was something I hadn't been taught
and so I went about trying to find best
practices my favorites came from the
field of survivorship research on people
who have made it out of life-and-death
situations the first thing successful
survivors do right is move quickly from
denial to acceptance
they don't dwell on what's been lost or
think about the unfairness of their
predicament
even in non life-threatening situations
that's so much easier said than done
but it can be done when Jimmy Carter
lost the election in 1980 he said that
he went home slept for an entire day and
awoke to what he called a new unwanted
potentially empty life unwanted that's
the tricky part
but only potentially empty Carter never
became president again but he did move
on to international conflict mediation
and the Nobel Peace Prize a second trait
of successful survivors is the ability
to set small goals and the willingness
to celebrate small wins recognizing even
small victories can help prevent a
descent into hopelessness in 2013 ski
racer Lindsey Vonn suffered a
catastrophic crash she tore her ACL MCL
meniscus and fractured her tibial
plateau I can't know whether she did any
wallowing but I do know that two days
after surgery she was doing core
strength exercises three weeks after
surgery she was on a bike as soon as she
could bear weight she did squat
she didn't actually ski for 203 days but
by the time she did she was strong
finally survivors get help but they also
give it giving help takes you out of
yourself it lets you be a rescuer not a
victim when Mickey Drexler was fired
from his role as CEO of the gap he found
another company to help in the form of
the struggling j.crew brand he invested
ten million dollars of his own money
took one tenth of his former salary and
managed to catapult the company from a
thirty million dollar operating loss to
a 37 million dollar profit in just a
year
move on from what's lost set small goals
get and give help whether these things
really make the difference I'm not sure
I'm trying what I do know is that all of
us at some point either already have or
will need to rebuild and I'm convinced
that this skill requires different that
this rebuilding requires different
skills than traditional resilience in
the wake of trauma almost everyone
experiences some depression and anxiety
most go on to move past those early
feelings and some become psychologically
stronger than they were before
psychologists call it post-traumatic
growth
it's what I'm hoping for when I talk
about rebuilding so you guessed it I
have to pull up my favorite graph one
more time inelastic deformation you bend
but you end up exactly where you were in
plastic deformation you bend or break
and you're going to end up different
what kind of different depends upon how
you rebuild bouncing back and rebuilding
our different skill sets let's develop
both thank you
you